Best known to Pawn Stars fans as "The Old
Man," Richard Harrison passed away on Monday,
June 25th at the age of 77 after a battle
with Parkinson's disease.
Harrison founded and operated the Las Vegas-based
World Famous Gold & Silver Pawn Shop, which
he opened in 1989.
Following his passing, the Pawn Stars team
paid tribute to Harrison, remembering the
man he was and the work ethic he had.
Harrison's son, Rick Harrison, for example,
shared two separate tributes to his father
on Instagram.
The first is a snap of the Old Man wearing
dark sunglasses and a fedora, with the touching
caption that read in part:
"He was my hero and I was fortunate to get
a very cool 'Old Man' as my dad.
That I got to share him with so many others
and they got to see what a great family man
he was is something I am grateful to have
experienced with him.
He lived a very full life [...] touched the
lives of people all over, teaching them the
value of loving your family, hard work, and
humor."
Rick later posted a photo of his father from
his days in the U.S. Navy with the caption:
"Today I lost a friend, a father, a teacher,
and so much more.
The Old Man lost his long battle with Parkinson's
this morning.
Love you Dad.
See you on the other side."
Similarly, Corey Harrison, also known as "Big
Hoss" to fans and family alike, remembered
his grandfather as more than just a family
member.
Harrison was more like a best friend to Corey,
who began helping out at the Gold & Silver
Pawn Shop when he was just 9 years old, later
becoming the store's full-time manager.
In his own Instagram tribute, he shared a
younger Harrison wearing a suit and striped
tie, writing:
"I was lucky enough to spend 15 years of my
life working with the Old Man.
He wasn't just a grandfather, he was truly
a best friend as well.
I'm truly blessed to have had him as a mentor.
He will be missed everyday."
Corey's childhood friend and fellow shop worker
Austin "Chumlee" Russell also remembered Harrison
as a kind, humorous man who offered honesty
and tough love when it mattered most.
He wrote on Twitter:
"It's hard to believe he is gone.
He was such a big part of my life and treated
me like family.
I will miss him greatly and carry the lessons
he taught me throughout my life.
You could always count on him to straighten
you out or make you laugh and both of those
a heartfelt tweet remembering their quirky
screen star by writing:
"We are deeply saddened by the loss of our
friend Richard 'The Old Man' Harrison, a beloved
member of the HISTORY and @pawnstars family.
He will be greatly missed for his wisdom and
candor.
Our thoughts are with the Harrison family
during this difficult time."
The Gold & Silver Pawn Shop Facebook page
also honored Harrison with a tribute that
read, in part:
"He will be remembered as the best father,
grandfather, and great-grandfather you could
have by his family and by fans as the sometimes
grumpy (always loving, however), often wisecracking,
and voice of absolute reason on the History
television show Pawn Stars."
One thing's for sure.